bonjour nous sommes avec manuel manière
l'état jeunes qui de dynamique du
générique intéressante bonjour je suis
avec manuel manuel est un jeu kid key
lamic dynamique ouais c'est ça
l'annuelle on va te poser la première
question traditionnelle est ce que tu
aimes assez de choses beaucoup de choses
- où énormément de choses auraient
énormément de choses tu peux le dire
j'aime énormément de choses dans la vie
dans la vie voilà qu'est ce que tu aimes
dans la vie beaucoup de choses à wayne
je pourrais dire tu aimes des choses
beaucoup de choses plein de choses
c'était vraiment beaucoup de choses oui
ne peut agacer
juste je rince beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de choses ou
pato bas à tous pas mal de choses j'aime
bien tu aimes bien de pas mal de choses
sur la
toile synthétique ce que tu as à dire
je m'appelle manuel et j'aime pas mal de
choses dans ac beaucoup tracé beaucoup
de choses sauf les walkman parce que ça
fait mal aux oreilles